das ist wirklich eine ziemliche
sensation zum ersten mal wurde ein film
in bakterien gespeichert dabei ist das
kein verrücktes frankenstein experiment
denn das erbgut von bakterienzellen
lebewesen also deren dna eignet sich
hervorragend als speichermedium in einem
gramm könnten unfassliche 400 milliarden
gigabyte gespeichert werden
beginnt jetzt die speicher revolution
oder sind die gefahren dieser gentechnik
viel zu groß jetzt wirklich 5000 fiction
herzlich willkommen ach was gab es alles
verrücktes bisher holografische speicher
magnet bleiben speicher tesafilm und und
und wie können möglichst viele daten
möglichst lange möglichst schnell auf
möglichst kleinem raum gespeichert
werden
es ist eine der zentralen fragen der
menschheit die mit buchdruck
schallplatte loch karte magnetbahn
festplatte ssd laufwerk immer besser
gelöst werden doch die suche hört nicht
auf jetzt ist man beim erbgut angelangt
zunächst der dna von bakterien dem des
darmbakteriums escherichia coli
vielen dank für den themenvorschlag an
dürfen frei ermöglicht wird das durch
ein werkzeug das vor knapp fünf jahren
in der gentechnik vorgestellt wurde die
forscherin emmanuel chabrier und
jennifer suttner veröffentlichen damals
einen artikel über eine methode mit der
sie jeden beliebigen abschnitt aus einer
dna ausschneiden und ersetzen konnten
christa kassen neuen werkzeug macht sich
einen abwehrmechanismus von bakterien zu
nutzen wenn sie von viren angegriffen
und überleben diese angriff bauen sie
sich teile der viren dna in ihre beta 1
es ist eine erinnerung an diesem
schädling dadurch kann er beim nächsten
mal durch diese gespeicherte dna
eigenschaft also diesen teil aus der
viren dna sofort erkannt und bekämpft
werden
genau diese technik die das zerschneiden
und modifizieren der dna ermöglicht wird
von kurt back up 9 genutzt mit diesem
werkzeug kann jetzt quasi nach lust und
laune in der dna herum geschnitten und
manipuliert werden stunden ganze
topische versuche im gang in china wird
bereits an menschen experimentiert dabei
werden die immunzellen gezielt verändert
so dass sie bei einem mann mit
lungenkrebs gezielt den tumor
attackieren diese versuche sind aber
nicht ohne bei einem mann mit einer
genetischen lebererkrankungen gegen das
in den usa vor 17 jahren mit einem
anderen verfahren schießt das
immunsystem geriet außer kontrolle und
er starb innerhalb von wenigen tagen
trotzdem setzten die
wissenschaftlerinnen große hoffnung in
chris backus 9
denn eigentlich so biologen kann es
jeder idiot bedienen mit diesem werkzeug
können preiswert und mit geringem
aufwand fällen für die
unterschiedlichsten zwecke manipuliert
werden weil es so einfach ist oder sagen
wir mal für wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen keine große hürde
mehr darstellt haben forscher um serge
shipman von der harvard university jetzt
die dna von escherichia coli
darmbakterien so manipuliert dass sie
dort ein bild von einer hand platzieren
konnten und sogar eine filmsequenz sind
die erste filmsequenz überhaupt wie vor
140 jahren bewies dass pferde beim
galopp zeitweise kein bein mehr am boden
haben das verrückte dabei 90 prozent der
bildinformationen konnten wieder aus der
vene herausgelesen werden dass chris
packard 9 wird risiken wie eine neue
studie herausgefunden hat so exakt wie
bisher gedacht ist das werkzeug gar
nicht gespart neuen verursacht
mutationen auch an anderen stellen des
erbgutes die nicht gewollt um sie
aufzuspüren wurden computer algorithmen
entwickelt die sie vorher sagen
doch die scheinen nur einen bruchteil
dieser veränderung im erbgut zu finden
schäfer von der stanford university und
ihr team
die hat jetzt herausgefunden dass
erhebliche mutation kann ich gefunden
werden für genmanipulation im labor
scheint das verfahren dabei gut zu
funktionieren
bei lebenden organismen aber nicht die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
untersuchen dafür mäuse bei denen
eingehen dass blindheit verursacht
verändert wurde
bei zwei mäusen das team an 1500 stellen
im erbgut veränderung bei mehr als 100
stellen waren es sogar größere bereiche
bei denen das erbgut ausgetauscht oder
gelöscht wurde
dabei warnen die forscherinnen und
forscher dass schon eine einzige
veränderung
große schäden verursachen könnte ihre
empfehlung verbesserung von küster klas
9 und die genaue beobachtung der
veränderung das würde dann auch zur
folge haben dass abgespeicherte filme
deutlich besser aussehen
vielleicht haben wir dann irgendwann
hamster braucht es zu hause in denen
alle spielfilme und serien abgespeichert
sind
die je gedreht wurden niedrigen
datenraten oder ein komplett ausgefallen
setzt können uns dann egal sein aber
vielleicht ist das auch ein bisschen zu
sehr frankenstein was man ihr schreibt
es in die kommentare ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt und halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video verpassen wollt dann wird mir
kein abo aufs auge unvergesslich denen
aus die glocke weiter geht es mit ein
mensch nach maß genmanipulation einfach
draufklicken wenn es euch interessiert
oder ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran